the Russos know exactly what they're
doing when they try to orchestrate the
most visceral involved audience
experience that a film can offer well a
great many people see you as a hero
there are some would prefer the word
vigilante IMAX as the closest thing we
have right now to a fully immersive
experience it surrounds you the sound
quality the image quality that scale the
image it just enhances your own movie
going experience incredibly stay out of
this one please
you only make us worse these sorts of
movies size matters it's the spectacle
is the event you know it's the
difference between watching a movie on
your iPhone and watching a movie
projected on your wall it's just the
scope of the scale the aspect ratio is
probably more well-suited for Marvel
losing this for anything because there's
a lot of verticality to the characters
they're carefully fly there are
characters who are 12 feet tall it adds
a whole nother dimensionality to the
story that we can tell you saying you'll
arrest me there will be consequences
the camera is getting more and more
versatile more and more mobile they're
amazing it's all very important values
to us in terms of how we approach action
music am
if you want to add scale and scope to
something it's the only way to do you
know what's about to happen do you
really want to punch your way out of
this large objects are bigger thrown at
people such as airplanes and cargo and
cars and pieces of buildings and I feel
like if you're in an IMAX experience and
you're standing there seeing a control
tower or flying in your face they just
blew my mind
what do we do we fight that scene is
gonna be great you have a lot of
superheroes coming together to fight one
another it's dramatic and it's powerful
and sounds like the IMAX was the
appropriate call you know I wouldn't do
this if I had any other choice but he's
my friend
so was I